[Music]
hi everybody welcome to ET live i'm
lauren zima i'm denne denne director i
almost forgot my own name wow they're so
focused on the globe so except for the
Golden Globe Awards and we're here to
give you the official preview of
Sunday's big show yes we are looking at
the biggest categories and the biggest
topics of conversation for Sunday
night's a big awards show we want to
know what you guys think of course to
let us know which movies and TV shows
you loved this year which shows you
think should win which movies should win
but won't win that kind of thing you can
leave your comments questions for us and
we'll get them here on e t--'s iPad
should we dive right in you know what I
love most about the Golden Globes is the
one award show actually there's a couple
but it's one of the only award shows
that includes the TV and film people
alright we're gonna start with TV we're
gonna buy we have basically been
predicting the races for TV series drama
and TV series comedy musical our staff
has some great picks
we're gonna break it down for you guys
now alright so best TV series drama the
nominees are the crown Game of Thrones I
don't know if you heard of it the hand
meets tail strangers things and this is
us it is a jam-packed race the winner
last year was the crown so a lot of
people are kind of expecting that one to
take again however you can't deny the
power of the Hulu series The Handmaid's
Tale that's the thing I would say this
is one of the most competitive
categories this is us has been in its
first two seasons such a breakout hit
the first Network drama in a long time
to get this kind of critical praise and
it's really the only Network drama in
the category still so we again went to
ET on lines staff to give us their
predictions our experts our TV movie
experts and what we're hearing probably
will land from our staffs predictions on
how the Globes work is The Handmaid's
Tale all y'all watched it you're
watching of course also won the Emmy
last year the first for a streaming
service so kind of expect that to take
the Golden Globe as well well and things
are interesting with Game of Thrones
right because it's been like on it's
been off we just found out by the way
we're not gonna get that final game of
Thrones season until 2019 so sorry about
that
how do I live I don't know what I'm
supposed to do with myself but so I
don't know I think that maybe Game of
Thrones won't take it this year because
it's going to kind of get those series
ending wins yes and people tend to award
an
way so let's move forward to a best TV
series comedy or musical we've got a lot
of great shows here as well blackish the
marvelous mrs. Mazal a master of non
smell a fun little new show from a show
time this year Will & Grace and Will &
Grace making a resurgence right so it's
a really interesting category this year
some new series some revived series but
what we're hearing from our predictors
at the ET online staff is that the
marvelous mrs. measles gonna take it
home because the acting on that show has
just been so great it's unparalleled but
also you have to realize that the people
were voting for these awards is the
Hollywood Foreign Press Association and
historically speaking these guys love to
award new shows especially in this
category last year Atlanta took it you
know so they love the shiny in noon so
we're expecting the marvelous mrs. Mazal
to sneak in there with the win a new
thing to play with exactly right
moving on to best TV limited series or
TV movie now there's been a lot of
controversy with this category because
in today's day and age what is a limited
series for example big little lies is in
it and everybody's saying whoa whoa whoa
big little lies now getting a second
season is it limited but what the
creators a big little eyes argued is hey
when all of the nominations were getting
figured out we didn't know a season two
was coming it was still absolutely so
we've also got Fargo feud Betty and Joan
the sinner with Jessica Biel and top of
the lake China girl now I got my man
come on come on
obvious you guys critical Darlene a
audience favorite big little lie swept
every award show so far leading up to
the Golden Globes including the Emmys so
I'm expecting it to shoot away and I
think and I think it will win that's the
category I think we can feel good about
look not saying anything negative about
the other shows here but big little lies
really seems to be like its standing out
from the rest and again like you said
it's this perfect combination to draw an
awards show audience in while also
rewarding good work it was an audience
favorite and a critical favorite you
can't really lose on this one and who
doesn't want to see another fabulous
speech from Nicole Kidman you know and
that's what I will say about this
category in particular that there's a
lot of a listers and movie stars who
made the move to TV and this is where
they are you got Feud you got Susan
Sarandon big little eyes of course
Nicole Kidman
reese witherspoon the sinner Jessica
Biel I mean the star wattage the star
power at this year's Golden Globes is
unmatched thanks to them making the move
to TV Oh a hundred percent and by the
way please let us know if you guys think
big little eyes should be the winner
here and how you're feeling about a
season two because I think we all are
feeling a little bit you know we love
season one so much please make season
two just as good
I talked to Laura Dern about on a red
carpet recently she says she thinks but
she's still had a hundred percent signed
on for it Ranade
yeah you know I'm hoping that they
actually bring more stars into season
two you know Naomi Watts has talked
about how she want to play play a part
in this show with her friends so be nice
to see some new blood I'm sure that
actresses aren't and beating down the
door to be on this show it's amazing
alright you want to take us into the
movie category right the movie category
you guys you know a lot of these are
some in excuse me there are a lot of
movies that showed up in the box office
you guys want to saw them but there's a
lot of critical and indie darlings as
well so we're gonna break it down right
now for Best Motion Picture Drama
we've got Dunkirk Christopher Nolan's
film the post with Tom Hanks and Meryl
Streep the shape of water which was
gorgeous call me by your name and three
billboards outside ed bean Missouri now
again friendly reminder the Hollywood
Foreign Press are the voting members of
the Golden Globes and they love
Guillermo del Toro and on this film the
shape of water was such a beautiful
beautiful fable beautifully done score
the acting I'm predicting that it should
and will win okay I'm telling you and
and like I said these people love him
yeah of them now you know and again it's
kind of about this tough situation to of
what is a movie really being looked at
for like call me by your name people
can't stop talking about the acting in
that movie Timothy sha'lame a kind of a
breakout star people are praising army
hammer for that role so it's a lot of
standout acting in that movie and then
you look at something like Dunkirk that
movie was all about the scope of it it's
this Christopher Nolan film a war epic
and you know the just the way he shot it
everybody couldn't stop talking and the
wide release I mean there were more eyes
on it you know it has more attention
that yeah it's kind of that that that
that plays in like who's gonna win you
know it's something to consider actually
alright well we'll see what happens but
shape of water I still haven't seen it
you saw oh it's beautiful
oh it's beautiful although it is not
to watch if you have to go the restroom
so then we move into Best Motion Picture
comedy or musical another thing I love
about the Globes is how it does award
comedy differently than drama so you get
a lot of really fun moments on stage too
because you have those comedians as part
of the crowd so we have got the disaster
artist starring James Franco I don't
know if we can call this a biopic it's
the real-life story of that famed cult
movie the room was critically panned yes
I mean kind of hilariously known as one
of the worst movies all time and it
became a favorite when people started
going to see it in theaters and just
sort of having fun with it some people
getting a little tipsy in the crowd so
James Franco made the story of the guy
who made that movie as a comedy then we
hadn't get out which some people kind of
talked about was get out really a true
comedy doesn't belong in this category
is a little blurred here and can create
a little controversy the greatest
showman obviously musical Hugh Jackman
Zac Efron I Tanya biopic starring Margot
Robbie and then ladybird ladybird at one
point I'm not sure if it still is but as
of a few weeks ago it was the best
reviewed film of all time and critically
on Rotten Tomatoes in terms of the
aggregate approval for critics so what
our predictors are saying is they
actually think get out should win I'll
be very surprising to me but at the same
time kind of like with Dunkirk there's a
lot of momentum for get out it's
obviously been praised widely by
audiences and critics I'm wondering if
they'll have the same kind of love from
the Hollywood Foreign Press but it'd be
kind of amazing to see it's a great
great movie it is a little funny there's
a little dark humour there you know what
I mean but it's also got a really
powerful message behind it I'd like to
see it win and huge hit at the box
office huge but what our predictors are
saying we'll win is Lady Bird again an
incredibly well reviewed movie I also
wonder with get out if it's gonna get a
little bit hurt by the fact that it came
out so long ago have people forgotten
how much they really really loved it
when it first hit a ladybird of course
coming from Greta Gerwig and it's kind
of a little bit of an autobiographical
tale being praised for the acting being
praised for the humor Laurie Metcalf
playing the mom in that movie is just
getting tons of praise and I talked to
her on a red carpet she said it's a
weird for me people forget this is she
hasn't been in that many movies she was
on Roseanne she's done a lot of theater
but this is like her second or thigh
mean she just hasn't been in many movies
and people are saying it's gonna be
Oscar buzz right of course it's anchored
by the amazing Saoirse Ronan and just
like Timothy and call me by her name
she's another standout another breakout
star this award season I say breakout in
the sense that like this movie is doing
wonders for her however this is not her
first time at the Golden Globes she was
first nominated which was 13 years old
for atonement so there's a lot of love
coming her way finally for Lady Burton I
feel like she could be the one to take
the the trophy price for Best Actress as
well okay and you guys are weighing in
with some comments that you love sure so
as well and hope she wins
Lady Bird really what you know
especially I think if you're a woman and
you had that mother-daughter
relationship people found the movie so
relatable but it's also just a teenage
story so again it's just a movie people
connected with so guys of course there
are the movies there are the TV shows
but there's also just the controversy
the Hollywood allegations a lot that's
gonna be talked about on the red carpet
on Sunday that is not usually discussed
at an awards show I don't know if you
guys have heard but because of
everything that's happened in Hollywood
the sexual assault allegations women
especially are pledging to wear black on
the red carpet as a showing of them
standing with other women and there's
also now the times up movement that got
a name for it earlier this week and it's
basically about saying hey we stand up
with women in every industry who have
experienced harassment and we're gonna
see what happens and that moment really
is a call to action initiative so out of
all of this darkness and all the
controversy and all these allegations
across industries
a lot of women powerful women in the
industry are putting their names behind
it to hopefully raise money for this
campaign and in fact we learned that
Reese Witherspoon will be responsible
for all the times up pins that the
presenters and everyone attending the
Golden Globe Awards I will be rocking
she's called in a favor to a costume
designer Aryan Phillips who designed the
pin in two weeks during the holiday
break
they manufacture like 500 in LA and
they'll be rocking those on Sunday
courtesy of Reese Witherspoon yeah we
were just hearing about that today
actually it's a if you haven't heard
about it sort of breaking news that
women are going to be wear
these pens as well and like you said the
times up movement is all about donating
you can donate to a legal defense fund
to help defend women who have
experienced that in their industry so
also we're hearing that women are gonna
be walking with other women on the
carpet as a stand of showing together
we're hearing that Reese Witherspoon is
expected to walk the carpet with Eva
Longoria by her side so it's gonna be
very different award chanson and Eva
Longoria even told the New York Times
like this moment everyone wearing black
at the Golden Globes is to send a
powerful message because in the past
these red carpets have been about
glamour what they look like and it's not
about that anymore it's about solidarity
and in fact I actually talked to Allison
Janney at the Palm Springs International
Film Festival
who said Reese was really instrumental
and spreading the word about everyone
wearing black you know she told her
friends her friends told other friends
and it just kind of it's a close-knit
circle I know yeah everyone will be
expecting everyone to be wearing black
so we'll see how that looks on Sunday we
have a caller from us coming in clay
says he's rooting for the post because
it's very timely definitely the message
of that movie it came out a little bit
late I'm not sure that a ton of people
have had a chance to see it yet but
Steven Spielberg behind it Tom makes
Meryl Streep like that absolutely and I
always love Meryl Streep at an awards
show I mean you talk to her on a red
carpet and she's like okay I have a
little booze in my purse or a couple
times I'm speaking of I mean the thing
about the Globes is it's kind of known
as sort of the most fun and playful
awards show of award season so that's
what's interesting is it's kind of the
first awards show since the
sexual-assault allegations came out it's
usually the more playful one but now
it's gonna have this message behind it
so the question is how will everyone
handle it especially the host Seth
Meyers usually he'd have a hilarious
monologue make a lot of jokes what will
he do so we actually talked to Seth a
little bit about this about how he's
going to handle everything when he's
hosting here's what he had to tell ET
we're just having a constant discussion
about it you know luckily we have a show
every night that approaches that tries
to talk about the news tries to also
make jokes about it while understanding
that the things we're talking about
aren't always funny so it'll be a
balance and trying to get the tone right
you don't also trying to remember that
even though it's a really difficult year
people did great work through that
difficulty and you want to make sure
that you also celebrate that as well I
have to see if there's any one's gonna
be able to find that balance between
comedy and really
the the the issues the serious issues
that are happening in the industry it's
Seth Meyers because as he put it he does
have this showed he does do that so I'm
looking forward to see what he has up a
sleeve this Sunday in fact when we
talked to him at that same interview we
asked who should be nervous about your
opening monologue and he said the people
who have we've been alluding to in these
sexual harassment allegations interest
so Oprah save Harvey Weinstein I don't
know yeah Oprah getting a big award
Sunday night's you this will be deMille
Award speech is probably gonna be
amazing and so powerful I can't wait for
that to I mean of all people to be
getting that award this year at this
time Oprah is the perfect person always
a champion of women and a champion of
Rights so really excited to see Oprah
and I agree with you Seth is the perfect
person because I mean first of all he
deals with stuff like this on a show
every single night but you know it's
often a late night type of host to me
the difference about Seth is he did this
for years on SNL he was a head writer on
Saturday Night Live and Saturday Night
Live is always balancing what's
happening in the real world with humor
and how you address that he was a girl
we can update I mean he addressed this
kind of stuff all the time in a comedic
way like I think he'll find a light
harder way about us so you know that's
not completely depressing the whole time
but at the same time address it so
everyone understands was actually going
on right and what sort of makes it
almost a little tenses this is people in
the room who have been affected directly
by all of this you know I mean we're all
watching it as audiences at home and of
course many women have had these
experiences and unfortunately but if
you're talking about the Harvey
Weinstein situation stuff like that it's
people in the room you guys so it's
gonna be a really captivating powerful
show to watch Sunday night I was gonna
say it's gonna be interesting to see how
this all plays out because you know it
is supposed to be playful but at the
same time there's some serious stuff
going on so we'll just have to see when
the 75th annual Golden Globes aired this
Sunday on NBC they're actually live
coast-to-coast by p.m. Pacific 8:00 p.m.
Eastern yes and of course et is going to
be on the red carpet with tons of
coverage we will have multiple cameras
on the carpet then we're also going to
be backstage with the winners as they
walk out right from winning that Golden
Globe to talk to them so make sure you
guys to check out ET online calm on
Sunday night of course we are going to
be on ET the show with a bunch of that
behind the scenes coverage and bringing
you everything up-to-the-minute and then
you and I will be back for a recap of
the Golden Globe Awards immediately
after the telecast on Sunday so you guys
stay tuned and thank you so much for
joining us today thanks everybody have a
great weekend
[Music]
you
[Music]